Okay. We've got our basic if statement, if n
equals 1 in Python, we print the string n equals
1. Else, n does not equal 1. Now notice anything
I put between these curly braces, this could be HTML,
this can be anything. This is just text. And
then finally, we finish this with end if. Notice there's
no space between end and if, that's all one word.
So when we go to our browser to run this,
and we reload the page, we see n does not
equal 1. Well that makes sense because we haven't specified n
in the URL. Now, I hope you're following along with
me, and let's go ahead and add n as a Get
parameter, and we'll make it equal to 1. Okay, so
we set n equals 1 in the URL here, and when
I hit Enter, hm, I expected this to say n equals
1. I wonder what happened. Maybe you can figure it out.